morgot may be the most incredibly
thought-provoking character in all of
elden ring when we first faced him on
the bridge outside of stormville castle
i'm sure we all hated his guts his
moveset was hard to learn and his
demeaning tone towards us as a tarnished
as we're lower than dirt didn't really
help us sympathize with him whatsoever
well
thou art of passing skill
warrior blood must truly run in thy
veins
tarnished then we see him again in the
battlefield outside of the capital city
where he tries to again stop us on our
journey of becoming elden lord
smoldering with that wretched flame of
ambition
finally we see him at the door of the
erd tree where he reveals to us his real
name and the responsibility he now holds
as the last remaining demigod who is
still truly devoted to the power of the
greater will in the golden order and you
know what else i'm devoted to increasing
the percentage of people who watch my
videos and are actually subscribed i
totally won't make you feel bad for not
subscribing by showing another cute
picture of my dog who gets belly rubs
and treats every time someone subs to
the channel okay i'll stop thank you
let's get into the video so why does
morgot use the fake name of margat in
our initial fight with him because
morgot was born in omen and omen babies
such as morgot and moog who are born of
royalty are kept in secret banished to
the sewers below the capital city for
the rest of their lives we can learn
more from the description of margaret
shackle which reads a fetish bathed in
golden magic shackles were used to bind
the accursed people called the omen and
these ones were made to keep a
particular omen under strictest
confinement though faint the shackles
still retained vestiges of power enough
to trap the once bound market on earth
if only for a short time since morgot
was born of royalty the horns indicating
his omen curse are not removed this
isn't the case for all babies born with
the omen curse most of these horns are
removed and the process of doing this
can be and mostly is fatal morgot is
aware and understands at least in his
mind that this curse puts a stain on the
royal name basically it looks bad and
because of this he understands that he
cannot be truly known as morgot born of
queen merica and godfrey but instead
uses the alias margaret to hide his true
identity now you might be thinking that
this is a poor effort to hide his
identity since he only changes his name
slightly and doesn't try to alter his
appearance at all well if you think
about it it doesn't really matter since
no one truly knew of his existence in
the first place other than marika and
godfrey by hiding his true name morgot
could leave the sewers without having to
stain the family name whatsoever he
likely changes it slightly because he
himself hates what that name represents
so what does he do outside of the sewers
other than beat our ass a few dozen
times let's listen to his dialogue after
we finally beat him outside of
stormville i shall remember
with thy meager flame
cower in fear
of the night
the hands of the fel omen shall brook
thee no quarter he's referring to the
night's cavalry which she would think
when said out loud would be spelled with
a k like the round table knights from
the middle ages but is instead the
knights cavalry spelled with an n
knowing that they can only be seen
roaming the lands between at night this
makes a lot of sense there are nine
cavalry nights that can be found with
the tenth member being the leader of the
cavalry margat we know him as the leader
from the item description of the knights
cavalry set which reads worn by the
knights cavalry who ride funeral steeds
who were once led by the fel omen and
were deliverers of death for great
warriors knights and champions if you
make your way to this sword monument
outside the walls of the capital city it
reads the second defense of landel the
fel omen stacks high the corpses of
heroes yet the erd tree remains unshaken
this is just yet another testament to
the power and determination that
margaret has toward the protection of
his city and the golden order in the
opening cinematic we can see margaret
battling with a red-haired soldier that
in my opinion is a younger much smaller
radon but could just be another red main
soldier it is also theorized that
margate created the century's torch
which are torches given to protectors of
the earth tree that hold a special
incantation which allows the barrier of
the torch to see assassins cloaked in
veils so even as a complete outcast to
his family and the lineage of it morgot
is still trying to protect the golden
order banished to the sewers and
betrayed by his family you'd think he'd
want to take a more similar path to his
omen twin brother moog which we can go
into more detail about in another video
but in my eyes it seems that morgot
hates himself and what he is he sees
himself as a stain a blemish that should
not exist we can see this from his
dialogue in the second stage of our
fight with him outside the erd tree the
thrones
stained by my curse
such shame i cannot bear
thy part in this
shall not be forgiven we can also see
from the description of morgot's cursed
greatsword that reads the accused blood
that morgot recanted and sealed away
reformed into this blade he truly
thought that no one loved him that no
one could love him because of the curse
he was born with we can tell that this
isn't true when we find godfrey cradling
morgot's body godfrey likely hasn't seen
morgoth since he was born but he looks
down on him in sadness for he is still
his son omen or not
it's been
a long while
morocco
maybe godfrey understands morgot's pain
after being banished from the lands
between when he lost his guidance of
grace and became the first tarnished
something like that makes you feel like
you're a stain a mistake godfrey can
relate to morgot more than ever in this
moment that he has with his son what
makes this even more sad is that the
birth of an omen used to be known as a
blessing of the crucible we can learn
from the crucible tale talisman that
reads a talisman fashioned from a scale
that embodies the aspects of various
creatures said to have grown on the
human body long ago a vestige of the
crucible of primordial life born
partially of devolution it was
considered a signifier of the divine in
ancient times but is now increasingly
disdained as an impurity as civilization
has advanced this doesn't read exactly
as the omen curse but it sounds so much
like it that it's hard not to relate
them i believe morgot is a misunderstood
character that holds a ton of bitter
anger and rightfully so he just wanted
to be an asset to his family in the
golden order but was shunned for a birth
defect that he couldn't control on top
of all of this his brothers and sisters
betrayed the only thing that he himself
wanted to serve they all had the right
to fight for the golden order but
instead went off on their own journeys
and their own beliefs and their own
paths where morgot calls them for what
they are
willful traitors
and it came all the way down to his
dying breath protecting the herd tree
protecting the golden order protecting
his family name and still referring to
himself as a
failure none may claim the title of
elder lord
thy deeds shall be met with
failure
just as i
truly is the most worthy successor to
godfrey and i think his father realizes
that when he returns to the lands
between to be granted audience once more
godfrey was once a barbarian war chief
named horolu who attracted queen america
with his incredible strength but this
barbarian warrior persona did not fit
the role of lord a lord is strong but is
also proper and well put together so to
suppress this rage for battle within him
he takes the beast regent suraj upon his
back to calm his rage and takes the name
of godfrey the first elden lord during
this time many wars were raged in order
to spread the dominance and influence of
the golden order over the lands between
godfrey commanded and led the
battlefield for many of these wars he
defeated the fire giants and their
one-eyed fel god who wanted to burn the
urgery and destroy the golden order all
of these giants were slain except for
one who was then cursed by queen america
to guard the flame for all eternity in
america's own words
hark
brave warriors
hark my lord godfrey
we commend your deeds
guidance hath delivered ye through each
ordeal to the place ye stand
put the giants to the sword and confine
the flame atop the mount
let a new epoch begin
an epoch glistening with life
brandish the elden ring
for the age of the earth tree it's also
known that godfrey battled with and
defeated the stormlord which is
theorized by many to be dragon lord
placiducks of the ancient dragons in
short godfrey led a campaign across the
lands between and was a very powerful
lord he and america went on to have
three children the omen twins morgot and
moog and then godwin the golden but as
we all know queen america starts to
doubt the influence of the golden order
she starts to find flaws within the
greater will and plots the downfall of
these outer gods during this godfrey had
defeated all of his enemies his campaign
had ended if you go to this sword
memorial outside of the smoldering
church it reads lord godfrey at last at
the end of his campaign his golden
armies unvanquished and unbowed yet
finds grace lost tattered and faded we
can also read from his armor set that
when his last worthy enemy fell it was
then that the hue of lord godfrey's eyes
faded with no one left to battle godfrey
had lost his guidance of grace and his
purpose it is at this time that america
instructs godfrey and his soldiers to
leave the lands between and to rage war
in lands far away where they will live
and die this made godfrey and his men
the very first tarnished and thus the
long march of the tarnish began where
they waged war in a far away land known
as the badlands where they lived
struggled and died just as instructed
during his time in the badlands he
became a simple warrior and is likely
where he had his daughter the philly lou
but at some point he was killed as we
can see in the opening cinematic where i
believe that suraj and godfrey are dead
and crucified in some way and when the
elden ring was shattered lord godfrey
was resurrected just like us as a
tarnished to seek queen america and
brandish the elden ring he returns to
the earth tree to see it burning and his
long lost neglected son more god dead
just outside the door i can't imagine
the anguish he feels at this moment
especially as he sees us walking up to
the door of the erd tree to become elden
lord as well however he may feel he
still respects our journey and the
struggle it must have been to make it to
this point but we must battle as we both
wish for the same thing to brandish the
elden ring for queen america but only
one can become elden lord and upon his
defeat he still respects our strength as
a true warrior should
lie
[Music]
the story of morgot and his father
godfrey is a sad one just like all of
the stories in elden ring godfrey likely
didn't have a choice when it came to the
banishment of his son to the sewers
below where he never saw him again
morgot lost his purpose at birth where
godfrey also lost his purpose later in
life they both wanted the same thing to
battle for what they believed in but in
the end they're in the same place lost
without guidance living without purpose
and seeking that purpose to their dying
breath and ultimately dying in the same
place together at the base of what gave
them life and death
thank you all for watching the video and
i hope you enjoyed it make sure to
subscribe so that we can get that
percentage up higher and higher every
single day your support means the world
to me and i cannot wait to make more
videos on elden ring lore have a great
rest of your day and i'll see you all in
the next video take care